التغييرات الطفيفة في سلوكك يمكن أن يكون
لها تأثير كبير
على حياتك ، فإن الحفاظ على هذه
العادات الصحية الخمس في سن الخمسين يمكن أن يضيف
أكثر من 10 سنوات إلى حياتك ،
واحد لا يدخن أبدًا 2 يحافظ على مؤشر كتلة الجسم الصحي.
شرب الكثير من الكحول وخمسة
يتناولون نظامًا غذائيًا صحيًا ، حيث تعمل
جميع أعضائك معًا
بما في ذلك قلبك
وعقلك وأمعائك ، لذا فإن اتباع نظام غذائي صحي
سيكون مفيدًا لجميعهم جميعًا ، قام
الباحثون بقياس الارتباط بين
هؤلاء الخمسة
عوامل نمط الحياة والوفيات المبكرة
باستخدام البيانات من 1980 إلى 2014.
ووجدوا أن النساء اللائي
تبنين العادات الخمس يعشن
14 عامًا أكثر من النساء اللائي لم
يتبعن الرجال الذين اتبعوا أسلوب الحياة أيضًا ، عاشوا
12 عامًا إضافية
وفقًا لدراسة كل من الخمس.
ترتبط العادات بانخفاض خطر
الوفاة من أمراض القلب
ويأمل باحثو السرطان أن
تشجع النتائج وتحفز الناس على تبني
أسلوب حياة أكثر صحة
هناك.  لا تكن أعذارًا ،
صحتك مهمة جدًا
إنها مهمة على المدى الطويل حتى
تنتظر أشياء
أخرى دقيقة الصحة اليوم أنا ريد
بينيون